So... what's your plan, Mr. Garrett?
How would you like to buy a bank?
What the hell do we know about banking?
Owning a bank is like owning the other
side of the real estate business.
There's a few complexities
you just left out.
-Like what?
-I'm sorry.
Did I not wake up black this morning?
'Cause I'm pretty sure I did.
Yep, still black.
I came here to try my hand at real estate.
You married a millionaire, Eunice?
I like seeing black men succeed.
Sometimes I even invest
some of my own money to back 'em.
I know you're smart and ambitious.
You and I both know that's not enough.
It is time that someone
shine a bright light on that
in order for things to change.
Are you starting to buy real estate
in white-only neighborhoods?
Think about all the good we can do
for the community.
Taking it to the man.
That's exactly what we're gonna do.
And just how in the hell
do you plan on pulling that off?
We get Matt to front for us.
You want me to what?
Be us to the rest of the world.
We can't set foot in the bank
unless we're the help.
Should've took limo driver
when you had the chance.
I don't know anything about banking.
I don't know how to buy a bank.
We'll teach you everything
you need to know.
You gotta learn how to talk
to rich white folks like you one of 'em.
And you can't fake a golf game.
Make me proud, son.
The whole country's talkin' about
how two Negroes managed to buy two banks
full of white folks' money
and loan it to other Negroes.
You should've known
you couldn't keep this a secret very long.
FBI, you're under arrest.
A black man tries to bring
other brothers up, that's intolerable.
Even a rigged game's fun to play, Bernard.
If this was easy, somebody else
would have done it a long time ago.
You a revolutionary.